in this video i'm going to talk about a
unit of length known as the meter which
you might have heard of before it's
really
probably the most used unit of length in
the world
and so the natural question is how long
is a meter
well one way to get a rough sense of a
meter is imagine a reasonably tall
basketball player so a good taller a
good bit taller than your average man so
a good bit taller than me i'm about
average height so that's your basketball
player there
he's got his basketball
he might be roughly two meters tall so
this would be
two meters
one meter and this lowercase m is short
for meter and then two meters
another way to think about a meter is
if you took a long step if you're let's
say seven or eight years old and if you
were to take a long step
you might travel about a meter so that's
your long step
right over
right over there it might be close to a
meter roughly it's not necessarily going
to be exactly a meter but it might be
close now a related
unit of length is known as the
centimeter
and you might already recognize that it
has the word
has the word meter in it and it also has
the word centi
now you might already know the word cent
ascent a hundred cents make a dollar you
might know the word century that's a
hundred years so you might say is this a
hundred meters you'd be kinda close but
kinda far off it's not a hundred meters
it's not bigger than a meter it's
actually a lot smaller than a meter a
centimeter a hundred of them will equal
one meter so one way to think about it
is if i write it in shorthand 100 and
you normally write it as lowercase c and
m so 100 centimeters are equal to
1 meter so on these pictures right over
here a centimeter would be
much smaller than a meter right over
there even that even what i just drew
there would be a lot less than a
centimeter and one way to think about a
centimeter it might be if you stick your
finger out
your finger
depending on how large your finger is
might be about a centimeter
wide
as a grown average sized man my my
finger is actually about two centimeters
wide if i take my index finger and if i
were to measure it i would approximate
it as about two centimeters
so a hundred centimeters make up a meter
which hopefully makes a little bit of
sense to you
now given what we've just learned about
meters and centimeters let's think about
what is better to measure with depending
on the size of the thing
so if i was looking at a
let's say a fairly tall tree of some
kind what would i want to measure that
with would i be more likely to measure
that in meters or would i be more likely
to measure that in
centimeters pause this video and think
about that
well a fairly tall tree is going to be a
lot taller than even this basketball
player so normally people are likely to
measure this in meters a reasonably tall
tree could be 10 meters or 20 meters or
even in certain cases 30 meters or
taller
now what if i were instead measuring
the length of a mouse so my best drawing
of a mouse here draws a little pause
kind of looks like a fish with a tail
but let's say that this is a mouse would
i measure this in meters or centimeters
well a mouse is much smaller in length
than a tree is tall so you would likely
measure this in centimeters a small mice
my a small mouse i should say might be
maybe
5
5 or 10 centimeters in length right over
here
now let's compare another way or decide
another way to think about whether we're
measuring in centimeters or meters
let's say that i went to the local
the local gymnasium and there's a pool
there
there's a pool that's the water in the
pool and i were to measure the length
and i know it is 25 something it's
either 25 meters or 25 centimeters
remember this is the pool at the gym
pause this video do you think this would
be 25 centimeters or 25 meters
well as you can imagine the length of a
pool this tall basketball player many of
them could lie down end to end to get to
this length of this pool so this would
be a 25 meter pool a 25 centimeter pool
that would be
maybe that actually would probably be
about the size of a cell phone or maybe
smaller or a little bit larger depending
on the cell phone that you're talking
about so for a pool you'd be talking in
terms of meters
what if we had a building of some kind
so this is a building right over here
and let's say it is a
three-story or let's call it it's a
four-story building and someone were to
say that it is
15 something tall would this be 15
meters tall or 15 centimeters tall
well 15 centimeters that might be a lego
building a real building would be 15
meters in this scenario now what if i
were to
say the length of my
thumb
the length of my thumb right over here
and i know it is 5 something this length
right over here
it is five
something it's either five meters or
five centimeters which one do you think
it is
well if it was five meters i would be a
very very very large giant my thumb
would be twice as tall or more than
twice as tall as a fairly tall
basketball player so this would be five
centimeters right over here so hopefully
that gives you a sense of meters and
centimeters and on khan academy there's
a lot more practice so you can get a
little bit more sense of estimating with
these or thinking about when one set of
one unit or the other is more
appropriate